missing link tattoo I'm here I need cash
the stay put till I get there see my
boyfriend got shot I don't even know
this to me the truth
you found her she's coming down hard or
something get her into detox I just met
the girl for the first time in years I
just don't feel like handing over to a
bunch of strangers want that tool not oh
I'm so sorry it's good to meet your
friends
always pick the wrong rednecks
man let's go I got no idea I eat this
guy's like that off what do they want
from you
they worked for my boyfriend please I
killed him
Lydia Carson would be traveling with
John Lake that warrant is for me you
could go home you got raised by three
stepfathers sir than me
I'm a murderer you face God for it but
not yet we'll get company made mistakes
mystically
I'll give everything done
you can see you right now
this is the last streak of sunlight
you're gonna see
whatever you got to do with Lydia
first you need to deal with me that's
your little girl why you seen her
missing link tattoo